bitte lassen sie ihr gepäck nicht
unbeaufsichtigt möchten sie am fenster
oder am gang sitzen ihr ticket und ihren
pass bitte stellen sie ihren koffer
bitter auf das band haben sie noch etwas
in den hosentaschen haben sie ein laptop
in der tasche
achtung bitte alle passagiere gebucht
auf british airways flug bei 123 nach
london werden zum flugsteig b 25 gebeten
achtung bitte dies ist der letzte aufruf
für den lufthansa flug lh 710 nach tokio
alle passagiere werden gebeten sich
umgehend zum flugsteig a 39 zu begeben
achtung bitte herr peter schlegel bitte
kommen sie zum informationsschalter in
der ankunftshalle b
meine damen und herren wir beginnen
jetzt mit dem boarding
wir rufen zunächst die reihen 20 bis 45
auf